so when alex invited me to give the the
keynote i wasn't i
hesitated for a very very long time
about which keynote i exactly was going
to give because i know that strange loop
you know is the audience likes very
techy very geeky things and that was the
kind of talk that i gave when i was here
the other the other time
and in fact the second edition of my
book was out you know late last year and
it but you know given everything that is
going on
i just could not get myself motivated to
just pretend that nothing is happening
and give a happy tacky talk
um so i just decided to go meta a little
bit i i hope you forgive me um
and uh
this is uh a talk about the future of
conferences and also about the past of
conferences um i have some uh
some
first
hand insights on organizing conferences
and in particular on organizing
conferences
online
for a while even before the pandemic
so that's
my talk is going to be sort of a
personal perspective on
on the lessons learned and um
sort of the big the big picture of
conferences um
so so here we go i'm going to let this
go a little bit
i'm going to stop talking and let
these old people
tell the story
okay so that's a little intro to to my
talk um
uh the talk is in five parts i talked
just a little bit about the origins of
conferences uh the value of conferences
the costs um the pandemic and uh what i
see as a the future of this thing that
we are doing here
um so
i did a little research on this
interesting site very geeky um history
site called the
scholarly societies project in the
university of waterloo
and so they map out all of these
professional and scholarly societies
throughout history uh well in the
western world at least
and so the oldest one is
in 1323 some obscure uh society in
france
um and then uh
throughout those uh you know
200 years or something 250 years or so
or something like that there were 30
documented then things started
accelerating so it's 43 between 1600 and
1700
229 in the next 100 years and then 230
in next 50 years so things started
accelerating there's more and more null
interest
and
you know activity around sharing
knowledge and sharing professional and
uh and scholarly knowledge
um
so
at the same time
not
not by coincidence there was also the
printing press that appeared um
in the 15th century in europe
and of course in the beginning it was
highly censored
but at some point with this
thirst for knowledge dissemination
this some of these societies started
playing a crucial role in disseminating
scholarly and professional technical
knowledge in the form of these journals
that they would publish and send out to
uh you know centers of knowledge known
as universities
um
so this is not a book that uh another
very geeky history book that lists all
of the
uh you know scientific serials since uh
16
something until 18 something this was
done by somebody who lived at the end of
the 18th century of the 19th century
so this is another interesting thing
that maps out you know the explosion of
these um
activities of knowledge knowledge
dissemination and knowledge sharing
and then of course uh you know
closer to where we are there's
some famous conferences that happen for
example the survey conferences in uh
early 20th century with a bunch of
physicists
that got together this is all very
famous people you might recognize um you
know einstein marie curie some
over there
and the same so the same group of people
a few years later this was in 1927 a
little older grayer hair which is sort
of like
us i guess when we also go to
conferences over the years
and we get a little older so this is
this is a long history of of people uh
sharing knowledge in you know in person
in go to a place um
and and share some professional
interests together and more even closer
in 1968 there was the famous
nato uh software engineering conferences
where the term software engineering was
coined
that also gathered a bunch of like
famous
you know people that started
kind of contributing to the start of the
field of software engineering
um
this is an incomplete list of
conferences that i either attended or
talked or organized um
i'm more on the academic side so the
academic side is a little uh beefier
than the industry side
but uh i i don't know about you guys but
i conferences for me is a big part of my
professional identity i identify with
the conferences that i help organize the
communities that go there every year
that we get older together um i made
you know lifelong friends in conferences
it's a it's uh it's absolutely a crucial
part of my professional identity at
least
so let me uh
pivot here to the value of conferences
right and that's a personal perspective
and i think it will resonate with some
of your experiences too um what what
value you know reflecting back what
value do i see in in these conferences
that i attended throughout my career and
my career spans more or less like this
and i attended my first conference in
1992
and now we are 19 in 2021 so we're about
30 years out
but you know i was going to
put something here but there's something
very big happened here
um and that was um that was uh the
internet and the web right things
exploded exponentially in terms of uh
content that is available at my finger
trip tips ways that we communicate with
each other
around the globe
so
my timeline of
my value the value that i see in
conferences has has changed you know
dynamically it has not been just one
thing from the beginning it there are
many things that have changed uh over
the years so
uh the first uh the first value i think
is uh the value that the people in the
16th century already
had in mind which is knowledge sharing
and acquisition that's
the main
reason for organizing conferences
um
and
i know about you but for me my
my the value that i see in this um in
knowledge sharing and acquisition in
conferences
decreased sort of sharply
as the amount of content on the web
has increased
sharply i mean it's no offense to
anybody including me who gives fantastic
talks here but
there's lots of interesting videos
already out there or and even more are
produced almost every day so there's
lots of content out there on the web
that i can watch uh you know with a
glass of wine in my home on my sleepers
and uh
no need to travel to have the exposure
to knowledge sharing the
the goal of knowledge sharing you don't
need to travel these days
this this has really been a
major shift from when i remember 30
years ago
30 years ago
if i wanted to get acquainted with the
latest and greatest research or the
latest and greatest technology i had to
go to conference
and and these days that's not the case
that is not the case so things have
changed
um
the second value is
networking so social networking meeting
new people and that has been incredibly
valuable for me
but again it has been sort of decreased
it was
very valuable when i was younger it was
even more valuable sometime in my mint
career
and then as i got a little older things
sort of started
not being so interesting but also
because it's actually easy to meet
people online too
i've made a lot of new collaborators and
and even companies uh on with people
that i met online that i never met in
real life
so that has changed too
uh yes we still meet lots of interesting
people in conferences but it's not the
only place that we meet interesting
people we can also meet interesting
people online without having to travel
so that has kind of decreased for me
another value is paid breaks in nice
places
and that definitely has not decreased
that that's never get all never gets old
so that's uh one of
you know my main motivations to to
attend conferences is to go to these
nice places and that's exactly you know
the business tourism exactly caters to
to people like us because we we need we
need a break right and any furthermore
if our employer is paying it's so much
the better right it's it's it's a way of
of knowing the world traveling around
the world meeting interesting people and
you don't need to
to pay and it's a wonderful perk uh from
an employer if you can get that those
kinds of perks so that never goes away
um so those are those i know about you
those are the three values that i got
out of uh uh conferences and i still get
uh some of them they they changed over
time
um what about the cost so again it's a
personal perspective
there are the costs of attending
conferences
and here's again my timeline
and things have also changed
quite irregularly over time so one is
the cost of time away from my family
which in the beginning was actually zero
or even decreasing because uh i did not
have really a family
until the point in which i had my
daughter and then suddenly things spiked
and uh you know
as my daughter was younger
you know a young child uh the cost of
being away from her was really almost
unbearable
and of course now she's uh almost going
to college so she doesn't need me
anymore so now that cost is gone
um so there's this bump uh in the in my
life i guess many of you uh probably
sympathize with with this uh curve too
um it's it's irregular
the second one sort of micro override i
don't know what to call it there's some
sort of a background sort of harassment
when you're part of certain categories
of people uh that uh that that happens
when you have a large crowd you know the
behavior in crowd is sometimes is a
little weird the dynamics and so that
has always been sort of a little kind of
nagging annoying thing of attending
conferences but again it has for me it
has decreased also because i'm getting
older but also because i just don't care
basically i stopped caring
uh that's basically what what is going
on
but you know when you're younger and you
don't know
it can be a big problem it can be a big
cost it's when you as you're getting
more experience then you can start to
just ignore
the third cost is one that i had
completely ignored or i was not even
aware for the most part of my career and
i guess that's probably true with many
of you here and this is a topic that
only really started kind of flashing our
eyes
more recently the topic of climate
change and sustainability
and the topic of our own carbon
emissions so you know some time
uh over the past uh
10 years i guess i that's when i really
started paying attention i started doing
changes in my lifestyle
to
um to mitigate my own personal concern
you know in carbon emissions so i
installed solar panels in my house i
drive an electric car
you know i try to
to be you know
a nice citizen but there's this
thing that no matter what you know i
have solar panels but then i travel to
san luis and uh and there goes you know
my my carbon budget for a whole year
because
airplane travel is
really a very unsustainable and very
dirty business basically
um and so this is this is a cost uh it's
a personal cost for those who care i
guess
i i do care and and it it
and you know it's not like the cost was
nothing and then
it was a lot it's just my awareness of
this cost was nothing and then suddenly
i became aware of this and i started
kind of giving a value to the cost of
traveling to conferences and becoming
you know quite concerned about the what
is going on
um
so air travel is is
when you travel to these conferences is
unavoidable jet fuel is difficult to
replace
um and uh it's you you basically um
waste a lot of uh
carbon emission you do make a lot of
carbon emissions just by the fact of
getting on an airplane and flying here
and you can
there are calculators out there that you
can use to tell you what the carbon
footprint of a trip from a to b uh in
the world yes
so just you know i i let me just expand
a little bit on on climate change and
conferences because it was something
that really started really nagging me at
some point in my life
of how much
you know i was doing all these
optimizations at home but then the world
is professional travel that was
completely uh exploding uh you know
making all my optimizations at home
pretty much irrelevant
so this is a you know my own co2
emissions due to air travel i counted
from 2015 until 2019 before the pandemic
how many trips i did
you know on an average what's my carbon
emissions and basically
if i in my estimate is that for the past
20 years i probably uh was responsible
for 330 tons of co2 which
first you know i got to these numbers
like what that like what does this mean
like a book so is this a lot is this a
little what what is going on so i
started again doing a little bit of
research to try to
illuminate myself about what this means
um and this is the best picture that i
could come up with that i could come up
with is that a if you have a tree
growing for 40 years
okay you have a tree growing for 40
years it's taking co2 out of the
atmosphere and storing trees are
basically storage co2 storage that's
what they are
and then if you take a a tree that's
been there for 40 years and you and you
burn it you're basically releasing all
those that co2 back to the atmosphere so
and and a normal kind of a medium-sized
tree something like that
for 40 years uh it corresponds more or
less on average for a ton one ton
so basically in my 330 tons
um
is basically 330
40 old trees
i'm burning a forest i've burned the
forest and it's just not nice
so it's not nice
so in other words costs
values
it's messy
it's not an easy picture
there's lots of reasons for continue to
do what we do traveling to conferences
and there's lots of reasons for changing
um and uh it's not clear exactly what
what exactly was right
you know what's the sweet spot in here
so we were discussing that before the
pandemic
some colleagues and and i at the acm um
special interest group in programming
languages
we started the committee on conferences
and climate change like really trying to
figure out because acm
organ is one of those professional
societies that organizes a lot of
conferences hundreds of conferences per
year um sig plan itself which is one
small part of sem organizes
i don't know i forget how many like uh
16 conferences a year something like
that every year
and so we started uh having this
discussion internally of whether we
should change uh anything or you know
what what should you do about climate
change and this is uh with michael hicks
uh jens palsberg and benjamin pierce
uh we
made a survey to the community with we
also we we then we brainstormed a lot we
wrote a report that's available uh
through that link about what the options
would be going forward for the
conferences in the sea in sick plan we
also wrote a conf communications of the
acm article
just before the pandemic it was in
february 2020.
um and that article was basically just
uh
suggesting that the way to go at it
because you know the the
the figure is so messy there's so many
pros and cons
that perhaps the best thing that we
could do was just back off and just
impose ourselves attacks
and the reason you know the reason being
that carbon and airplane travel and all
that stuff it's so cheap because
essentially a lot of the fossil fuel
industry is being subsidized the real
costs are are not being passed on to the
industry themselves but they're being
subsidized
by means of you know wars and security
and all of that stuff
uh and so
perhaps it's time that we voluntarily
tax ourselves since the governments seem
not to want to do that
and and so we would perhaps
when organizing conferences in the acm
we would make things more expensive and
what we would do with the rest of the
money we would subsidize you know
climate change uh friendly activities um
being you know lo organization of local
conferences or uh things other things
that people might want to to do with
that money so that was sort of our our
position at the time before the pandemic
hit
and then uh the pandemic hit
but uh so the the possible actions would
be first of all also in that report uh
the the first thing that we need to do
is to quantify like how much really is
the what's the carbon footprint of
strange look
it's possible to actually estimate it's
not exact science but as estimates you
know can figure out where people are
coming from
uh run the co2 calculator
figure out other sustainability
indicators from the venue here and you
can kind of
have an estimate for what's the carbon
footprint here and we did that
exercise for a collection of uh sig plan
conferences for the past 10 years we had
the data the attendance data and so we
did uh we ran the the statistics we we
saw you know exactly what was going on
interesting i mean i could go into
details but basically it's the same
messy picture right because when
you know uh we organize conferences all
over the world so sometimes the
conferences are in paris other times
they are in japan other times are in
india or in the us they're all over the
world it's very clear from the numbers
that whenever we go away from the that
axis of north america europe
eastern north america western europe
if we get away from that axis
the carbon footprint is much higher
that's rule of thumb so there's a sweet
spot around you know paris london kind
of thing and then boston new york
pittsburgh kind of thing that is
sort of the minimum but once we start
going more to the west or more to the
east or more to the south
um
the carbon footprint increases of the
conferences that's sort of the rule of
thumb
but it's important to know okay we have
to know we have to start quantifying
these things
um so another thing that we could do
would be offer carbon offsets upon
registration but you know carbon offsets
are sort of an iffy kind of thing not
everybody agrees that they're a good
solution
we rethinking pc meetings and i i'm
almost embarrassed to talk about this
because it's a very academic thing it's
just a very stupid thing thank god the
pandemic got rid of all the in-person pc
meetings there's no more in-person pc
meetings anymore these are like meetings
where the the program committee would
fly
just to decide which papers were going
to be accepted okay that's that was what
busy meetings are
um
inc so incremental changes small
incremental changes to conferences or
deeper exchanges to conferences we had a
long list of other things that could do
and then um
that implemented carbon tax was the
thing that that we kind of just decided
to write on the communications of the
sem article
um
all right and then the the pandemic hit
and now we had
is for better or for worse
uh voluntarily or involuntarily we have
18
months of experience in virtual events
and virtual conferences so
this was kind of a rush
and it was a scramble in the beginning i
was involved in organizing icm
conferences at the time i was called up
to create
sort of an emergency task force in the
acm
to figure out because the acm you know
there were like a 170 conferences that
the acm was planning with contracts
signed right there was contract signed
already that year with venues and stuff
so they were scrambling to figure out
like we cancel everything do we go
online what's going on so we wrote a
kind of a
best practices guide for organizing
virtual conferences
um
and then the conference that i was
organizing exe 2020
they called me up to to be the
virtualization chair
i ended up actually coding a whole
platform myself with john bell
um to uh to support the conference the
virtual conference um and that was the
beginning of cloud we called it clouder
and then throughout that summer last
year more conferences in the sem wanted
to use that platform we we made the
platform available but obviously we are
academics we could not sustain that but
uh luckily then at some point in the
fall
one person that we met in the conference
that we organized
volunteered to actually take over and
start creating a business out of of
clouder and so they we formed a company
called clouder
which is a um
a company and com community interest
company which is sort of a non-profit in
the uk
uh it's so basically which is a company
that operates cloud clouder being an
open source project
um and uh so there were more virtual
conferences on cloudera throughout the
spring and the winter and
we recently
renamed
the the product meet space app uh
clowder is still the company but the
product is called mid space so there's
lots of things that happen in lots of
experience lots of virtual conferences
lots of interesting experimentations
ourselves with the platform to figure
out what exactly works better what
doesn't work what seems to have more
engagement what seems to have less
engagement so it was an interesting time
for experimenting so here's some lessons
learned and we still we still don't know
you know there's lots there's lots of
things that we still don't know but here
are some things that we already know
with respect to virtual conferences that
video presentations actually are better
than in person
and the reason being
that there's a lot less technical snafus
people are a little more relaxed when
they are shooting themselves and they're
not talking in front of a crowd
um and uh you know there's a
and then there's also the part of
for the people watching you can watch at
your own time so you can replay later
there's all sorts of uh of things that
you can do if you have the video
you have a permanent archival artifact
that you can watch you can disseminate
around the world it's much wider reach
so much bigger inclusion right you can
at least force it you know for like
academic conferences we suddenly had the
the you know videos uh that were being
watched in china
like with in china being always ten
times of the rest of the world right um
and that that prior to you know when we
did not have videos those people would
be locked out those people would not
have come to the conference
and so so it's it's it really makes you
think you know um
we can reach a lot more people if we
actually uh
video videotape the talks and make them
available
um things for accessibility like closed
captions and
lip reading and all of that all of that
stuff is also better if you have the
video now we have a wonderful thing here
of live closed captions i was just
talking with alex this is a great thing
um
but uh with and it requires a person for
live captioning but for videos it
doesn't require a person you can do a
fair amount with just a translation um
after you know post processing of the
video so there's
there's a very good there's very lots of
good reasons for actually doing video
presentations that is those live
streaming is also possible and it's
technically perfectly fine in fact we're
live streaming right now um
the value of live streaming varies
that's what we that's what we found out
and the reason is that
again when you go into the virtual space
people aren't necessarily
on the same page literally so people may
watch later right say they may be busy
right now but they want to watch a
little later an hour later or something
like that so live live streaming can be
engaging it's definitely more more
engaging because things can go wrong
right
but uh but uh the value varies there's
also another problem with live streaming
which is uh
one that we found out very
quickly in the in the academic
conferences that i tend to attend which
is that they are
they they have community around the
world
and so we have to deal with time zones
you know we're awake here but people in
australia are sleeping right now
and they get very upset
let me tell you
if you live stream only once a day in a
way that is convenient for americans and
europeans
uh so this is a quite a very vocal
community on the other side of the world
um that does not like that they are
being forced to to be expected to be
awake in the middle of the night and
rightly so
um
a
live q a so there's there's the talk and
that's the thing that i say that
actually works better in in videos but
then there's the the question in
answering question and answering the
live
is actually work also works better uh i
think in in online then it works here
for a number of reasons for when people
can start already typing the questions
even before the speaker is
ended talking
the speaker can actually see that the
questions being typed as the speaker is
speaking is or the video is playing so
there can be already an engagement as
the talk is playing and the speaker can
see what the questions that are being
asked and respond on the chat for
example so there's
we found many live q and a's to be quite
engaging and more thoughtful the
questions were more thoughtful because
people had more time to think about what
they were going to ask
um so this this definitely for video
sharing for value number one video
knowledge sharing normal sharing there
are lots of interesting uh good things
about going online with the conferences
and you know you have sort of this
experience that you again it's you know
a video you know how to play it you can
stop you can
be interrupted by your kid come back
again it's still there you didn't miss
anything so that's that's a good thing
uh the networking the the social
networking in uh virtual conferences
ranges from non-existent
to okayish and i have not found a
platform including uh mid-space where
it's a great experience
no
there's no there's we're not there
there's
nobody's there yet it's not a great
experience the social part of online
conferences
on the other hand it's very clear that
the platform matters and there's a
there's a very big difference from doing
a webinar you know a zoom webinar or
whatever for doing and and using some of
these newer platforms like like mid
space and others that pay attention to
the interaction between the participants
so supporting interaction between
persistent supporting you know having
the bios on there
available having a tags emoticons uh you
know live interaction all that matters
uh for the engagement
um so social rooms shuffle rooms things
sponsor booths all stuff that can be
thought of and designed and placed in
the platform that that can actually
improve things um still not as great as
in person social networking but uh but
not as bad as like a webinar kind of
thing a webinar is like the worst like
the baseline the bad baseline of the of
these things
um
so you know you can start up video rooms
people can start up their their own
video rooms they can be public private
there's all sorts of things that can be
designed
and are being designed by all of these
you know meat space and other platforms
that are experimented in implementing
this space
paid breaks is a total fail
okay so first of all uh well you are
being paid because you're expected to be
at work so but you are not being you
know don't have a break you're expected
to still do your normal job and then uh
you know watch the talks and this is a
complete fail this is just not going to
work
if we're ever going to
organize conferences online
for reals
this needs to be rethought because
there's no way that people can have the
mental cycles to have eight hours of
work and then uh watch for hours of
videos just it's not gonna work
um so this has been quite a challenge um
on the other hand which is sort of the
same
the other side of the same coin is that
the time away from family is a total win
because you don't leave home so you can
again you can stop the video and uh give
food to your daughter or and come back
again but and and so it's it's great
this this part was great so there's no
cost
uh the the harassment costs there's
fewer opportunities also great there's a
lot less opportunities for harassment in
fact we we haven't seen any harassment
at least in the the conferences that
have been done on mid-space in mid-space
we haven't seen anything of that sort
um
and uh for uh carbon emissions it's also
a total win so this is uh and and i will
expand a little bit more on this but uh
but it's clear that virtual conferences
have a much lower carbon footprint than
than in person conferences
so lessons learned the overall
experience with respect to knowledge
sharing and the environment because this
is online because we can produce videos
it's part of that same story of the
content that exists online right so it's
it's pretty good it's pretty good
uh we just with respect to the
expectations of a conference you know
the social parts the the the serendipity
bumping into other people that's
ranges from terrible
to
okayish
um and where the platforms matter so
there seems to be a lot of interesting
new designs in here that may be
coming up and people are experimenting
with hopefully this will get better
but another thing that we also
learned and this is one of the hardest
lessons
to
tell the organizers of this conference
is that the organization all decisions
matter a lot i mean just on me just in
mid space we've had conferences that
were not good at all and we had
conference attractions pretty good and
the platform is exactly the same didn't
change
and why because the organizers had a
completely different way of designing
the conference
you know the the kinds of things that
activities that they had the attendees
doing
um you know the the
time zones distributions the you know
smaller uh
meaningful
small group interactions versus
not even thinking about it is like a
huge
spectrum of decisions that the
organizers can now now have to make and
what happens for a lot of these
organizers is that they don't even know
that they they have now this all of
these options and so they don't they
don't even think they just say okay it's
like a zoom meeting or whatever and they
don't think about all the other things
that they probably should be thinking
and and things fall flat whereas we've
had other conferences where the
organizers were really
thoughtful and engaged and thinking
up front about how things were going to
enroll online and and those conferences
were absolutely really they were not as
good as in in-person conferences but
they were pretty good
so that matters a lot
um so let me just make a little detour
here about a pre-pandemic case study of
a virtual conference that's the open
simulator community conference which is
something that i have been involved for
the past you know n years and the
conference started in
2013 and it's a it's a virtual
conference has always been a virtual
conference because this is a virtual
community a worldwide virtual community
this is a virtual environment like a 3d
kind of thing you guys remember second
life it's sort of the same it's the same
uh client code of second life the server
was completely
redone i i'm one of the developers of
the server but uh it provides the same
kind of environment so you know at some
point we decided to organize this annual
community conference
and so these are people who are
aficionados of of these kinds of
environments um
so you know we made a whole
venue conference venue with
conference rooms uh
plenary
rooms like like this one uh poster
sessions uh you name it expo areas but
of course it's being virtual reality you
can get a little wilder than just you
know the constraints of the real world
um and there's also social events you
know there's people doing um live
streaming live music uh and that you
know other people put their avatars
dancing and stuff like that so
but again this is a community that that
that already lives for this so they know
this they don't need to be taught about
these kinds of environments so the
learning curve here is is not none
for them
um so but osc numbers it's two days
typically
a weekend
there has been one every year that the
next one is uh in december
about 500 people every year
um
dozens of speakers many satellites
events it's a real conference except
that it's it has always been online
and the stack is that it so there's a
second life viewer
and then there's the open simulator
server
uh on the back end which is a server
that actually runs on one of my one of
my physical servers at uci
which is a dell poweredge and an old one
and the viewers are run on regular
laptops so i tried to make an estimate
for the
carbon footprint of oscc and i i mean i
did best as i could and i i guess you
know this is just an estimate but
uh i was looking at the specs for um
energy consumption and carbon emissions
of of the server and that's what i found
about 18
kilos per week so you know
assuming that we are testing the server
for a week or whatever this is very high
because there's more stuff running on on
that server but so 18 kilos for that
week of the conference um for the
participants laptops again i was looking
at the
specs online about 40
these are the numbers that i that i ran
into so if we have 500 participants for
two days it's about a total of 120 kilos
for the whole thing
thank you
thanks
and then the network traffic that one i
could not find
any good documentation and i don't know
if anybody uh knows i'd be
glad to have a better estimate but you
know just
complete a number out of my back pocket
500 kilos half a ton just i just for
sending the packets around the world
through the servers
so basically we have a total co2
emissions of less than a ton uh then
this i think this is very high actually
i think this is a very high estimate 750
for the whole thing 500 people right so
compare that with the carbon emissions
of a conference
with eight
800 500 people
flying all over the world from with an
average of i don't know a ton
just on airfare
on the air travel plus the you know the
hotels that are not very efficient and
stuff like that so it's it's a big it's
it's a big difference that's the bottom
line it's a lot lower like a lot several
orders of magnitude lower so this is a
good thing
so uh the future
i wish i had a crystal ball but i don't
um
some predictions so i think that
in-person events will not go away
you know there's clear indication that
people are eager to resume go back to
normal
and i don't know if we'll ever go back
to normal
but uh i think that then we will go back
to some new normal like i see i can see
it already in my lectures in in
university that we we we went back to
the classroom but it's not the same
thing
we are doing
recordings we are allowing students to
watch the the lectures uh you know later
on there's all sorts of hybridization
going on it's not the same thing
and i suspect that that
that's going to happen the same with
conference that people are here to
resume the normal but the norm is not
going to be the same and
virtual participation is here to stay i
think there's early signs that there is
a strong demand for it not just not just
because of concerns with the pandemic or
whatever but because of people actually
have you know those bumps of children
for example they cannot travel or
they have a
something in their work that they cannot
really leave then but they won't they
really want to uh see what's going on in
the conference and so there's there's
demand for it
um so
hybrids and nobody really knows what
this means and there are many modes of
hybrid
so one one
possible version of hybrid is that lots
of large online events
and a few smaller physical ones so
uh you know for for having more
meaningful interactions you have within
smaller groups at least in an academic
world okay
you know small workshops tend to be more
worthwhile than the large conferences
um or it can be the other way around
lots of small online events and then a
few were very large conferences like you
know instead of sit plan having 17
conferences every year maybe we should
just organize one large conference per
year just one and then everything else
should be an online event for example
or could be alternating between online
and physical so one year it's online
another year is going to be physical so
we can we could go hybridization that
way or it or you could go hybridization
the hard way which is what alex is
trying to do here this year which is
that you are catering both for in-person
attendees and online attendees at the
same time so you basically have the
double of the work because you're
organizing two events really and and
probably the double of the costs too
um because again you are organizing to
events
uh so these are all all the
possibilities i don't know where the
chips will fall
but i am pretty sure that normal is not
going to be normal again it's going to
be something slightly different and and
online events are here to stay and
online content is here to stay with
respect to to the organizational
conferences
so it's a time to think
um you know what do we value
what costs are we willing to incur
and moreover how can we leverage
technology to to technology to innovate
in this 123
trillion um
space which is the business
uh tourism
space um and basically beyond far faster
horses and faster horses here mean
basically doing what we were already
doing in the 16th century except now
that
with a lot more people
everybody coming from all over the world
and and basically the same thing but
just bigger right
can we go beyond that metaphor or what
what other interesting things can what
other forms of of of conferencing can
you envision perhaps leveraging
technology that will
create something different it's not same
thing but something different but
something more worthwhile and more
modern in a way
so let me tell you the challenges
technology is the easy part actually as
we very quickly found out at developing
clouder
and
the pieces are all there
you know live streaming
they're very good platforms for live
streaming aws is a fantastic
infrastructure for live streaming
applications built on top of it
you know text chatting live
interaction all that stuff it's fun to
develop it's super fun to develop and
and the technology is not the problem
technology is already there
the the the challenges are all social
and um and psychological
and those are the ones that are really
difficult that we stress that's
struggling because
the sense of presence is something that
we
um
we don't even realize but we take that's
what we bump into when we are placed in
or displaced in a foreign uh space like
here
and we we are present we don't even
realize it that we are we we are present
we know that we are here right i can see
you you can see me we are here i'm not
at home
and and the fact that i am surrounded by
the these walls and this hotel
is always a reminder that i'm in some
non-usual place and this is a special
event whether if i'm at home
sitting in my office
um
it's really difficult to remember that
i'm attending a conference it's it's
it's there's a disconnect i'm there i'm
i'm at home
right i'm not at the conference but my
mind wants to be at the conference but
but my eyes are not at the conference
so the mental space is a problem you
know also because you're constant
perhaps sometimes you're interrupted by
your kids by your spouse um and and
that's uh it's difficult to
which is something that doesn't happen
when you
travel and you are here you're
automatically not interrupted
um time zones are a problem uh for
certain conferences
and also people certain many people
actually quite reluctant in uh
interacting online they just don't like
it many people just don't like to
interact online maybe maybe those people
will eventually die very soon i don't
know but yeah
the newer generation the newest
generation seems to be more a lot more
comfortable with these things but some
but i i actually know a lot of people
who don't like to interact online
um
so these are the challenges and i i
don't know what's going to happen but
but some of this may go away with
imagine this thought experiment so
imagine that you have a pandemic that
lasts 20 years that you have the 20 20
year that lasts 20 years
that you can't travel or imagine that
you have prohibitively expensive air
travel and you you can't travel which
might happen you know if we stopped
subsidizing uh the fossil fuel industry
um
what would happen would we regress to
the 16th century and become everything
would become local and we would you know
break our global connections i don't
think so
i think that
given from what we saw this last year
how quickly everybody was
able to pivot to online to functioning
online
i think that we would be able to figure
out the way of making these conferences
work online you know
do the extra steps that we need to do to
make these events interesting on as an
online experience i think it will happen
uh now if everybody starts to say oh no
no i don't want to go there let's go
back to travel you know
let's go back to
to in person then that you know this may
not happen until until it actually some
one of those nasty things uh forces us
to solve the problem
uh so i i'll leave you with these
thoughts i wish i had
more uh answers um but i actually have a
lot of questions interesting
observations about what what i saw
working what i saw not working and i
hope that we will find a way of
finding a middle point between this very
unsustainable way of life and something
that that continues to be worthwhile and
professionally fulfilling thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you